aujourd'hui on se trouve au Musée
départemental Maurice Denis à
Saint-Germain-en-Laye pour un cours de
bachata en effet le musée organise le 14
février le jour de la Saint-Valentin une
initiation c'est parti
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour
il y a trois pas de base le basique
[Musique]
et on va marquer A4 et marquer à 8
marquez ça veut dire simplement je vais
faire un touch sur le pied ou je ne suis
pas en appli de poids de corps d'accord
1 2 3 et je te tote 4 d'accord
3 5 6 7 et 8 l'avant arrière là encore
une fois le tour d'effet miroir donc si
j'avance vous préférez on y va 3 4 1
2 3 et là je vais faire mon top juste à
côté
[Musique]
5 6 7 et 8 très bien et le même le même
pas qu'on va faire sur place qu'on
appelle un peu la montada c'est un peu
d'escalier et c'est comme si on disait
tout simplement
1 2 3 et je touche 4 et je recommence 3
5 6 7 et 8
et on est sur des mouvements que ça part
qui s'apparente plus
de la danse urbaine que la bachata de
base qui est une base Dominicaine et mon
but à moi ça va être du coup de vous
mettre en valeur vous avez une princesse
le temps de 3 minutes à peu près là je
prends mon pouce vous venez simplement
poser sur le pouce et moi je vais
simplement venir
ici je suis dans une phase de respect je
vais venir ici l'omoplate et vous allez
chercher la connexion
[Musique]
comptez 14 euros par personne pour deux
heures de cours de danse le soir de la
Saint-Valentin de 19h à 21h l'initiation
est réservée à une dizaine de couples
alors n'oubliez pas de vous inscrire si
vous êtes intéressé donc rendez-vous le
14 février pour apprendre les pas de
base qu'on vient de voir ensemble
merci beaucoup merci à vous à bientôt